what's up everyone welcome back to the
youtube channel for
another conversation about dinner in
america a movie that i'm not gonna shut
up about and that you need to see i have
kyle gelner here what is up how are you
doing i'm good how are you i am doing
very well because this movie is finally
getting the release it deserves ah i
know
long time long time coming it was like
we hit sundance and then the world
exploded and everything
you know it's been like this uphill
battle since but we finally
we finally got there it's finally coming
it is about down time i'm so happy um
obviously every collaboration is
different but you've worked with some
pretty cool people over the years so do
you find that there are any constants
there you know like a consistent quality
you like to see in the people that
you're about to work with when you sign
on for a new project
i mean
you want somebody who knows what they're
talking about first of all
you know that's that's important you
want somebody who feels passionate about
the project they're making you know some
people just feel like hired guns
and they're like i know how to put the
pieces together and make a picture and
make it look good and this and that
and that's fine sometimes those movies
turn out great but i like the people who
like
these movies mean
everything to them you know they've
worked super hard to get it off the
ground they sometimes have
written it themselves or they've
developed in themselves there's just
there's just a passion behind it and
something like dinner in america
you know with adam having
i mean this guy wrote it edit it
directed it i mean he did everything
this was like his baby these people were
so
close to him the script was so close to
him and when you talk to him about it
you know that world he's created he
knows it inside and out and
it just excites you to want to jump into
that world you know with somebody who
knows it so well like you want to be a
part of it you want to help create it
you want to help build it um
so i you know
it's kind of like a vibe thing it's a
feeling it's it's how somebody talks
about something it's how somebody
it's almost kind of hard to put into
words like you sort of almost just get
an instinct about somebody you know and
and adam was one of those guys when when
i
facetimed with him to talk about the
film and we talked for like three and a
half hours we just
just couldn't stop
talking it was like hanging out with a
friend you know even though we had just
met and
you know in that moment you're like oh
man please let me do this with you
let's jump into uh
finding simon a little bit here because
the last time we spoke you emphasized
how adam really let you and emily be the
simon and patty that you wanted to be so
can you tell us a little bit about
finding the character and maybe you know
what what are some of the biggest
differences between the character you
read on the page day one and what we see
in the final film
so yeah like you said
like the best part about that was like
adam really trusted me and emily and we
really trusted adam so adam let us
find
these characters and create these
characters and he you know he would kind
of gently guide us a little bit if if we
wanted to you know talk about
taking things in one direction or
another and if things didn't feel right
we would we would start shifting the
nice thing was we had a little bit of
time
and then we also had like three weeks of
time
in detroit before we started shooting
you know and we got to record all the
music and we got to do everything and
really recording the music helped and
getting into the wardrobe and getting
into the haircut
that all changes things it changes your
physicality it changes how you move it
changes how you feel
those types of things for me are really
helpful because they're really tangible
you know like
the way somebody looks at you when you
walk into a store with like your mohawk
and your your jacket and your stuff it
it changes people look at you
differently you know they treat you
differently
um
and then before we got to detroit it was
little things like there's there's kind
of like an animal
thing
to simon there's like a primal thing to
simon like if you watch there's all
these little things like when he eats he
like guards his food
you know it's little things like that or
coming up with the way he he he walks
there's like a swagger there's an
intention to the way he moves it's it's
like a shark he never stops moving
forward
you know
so it was finding those things but the
but the hardest part almost was
being comfortable with those things and
being comfortable with the abrasiveness
of him and and
how gnarly he is because you know
everyday society you're taught not to be
like that
so it's almost like breaking these these
norms that i would
i would go out into the world with not
just on set but i would take it out into
the world to just like put it on and
it's it's a strange feeling like i'm you
know i'm somebody who's yes please thank
you very much and then you know you
suddenly start dropping that stuff and
you're being short with people or people
can go [ __ ] themselves or like [ __ ]
whatever you know it
it changes a lot
um
so it was really just trying a bunch of
different skins on until
i felt like we were
on the right path and then
again it was super helpful to get out to
detroit
early
to meet emily and
get to see what emily was doing with
patty and get to really you know get
face to face with adam and and just
sort of be like does this work let's see
if this works let's see if this doesn't
let's play with these things
and then you know recording the music
was was extremely helpful and
informative just to get into that
mindset and lifestyle and
and
it was really just piecing them together
bit by bit and then we shot for a day or
two and after about 48 hours we really
felt hello we really felt um
comfortable and then by like the first
week we were just sort of flying
and we were able to just push it further
and further which was great and that's a
testament to emily and adam and
everybody trusting each other to really
just push this thing to 11 the whole
time
so many follow-ups about that first we
get a little taste of this in the movie
and it doesn't really need all these
additional details but i find that i get
obsessive over backstory information
when i really fall hard for characters
all those those mannerisms and the
person that simon's become did you ever
come up with any you know like major
life events that kind of added up to all
that and inspired him to you know carry
himself the way that he does
yeah i mean i think it was just you know
that that dinner with his family is very
telling
you know i think i think he's pushing
he's pushing back against that he's
pushing back against
his upbringing he's pushing back against
where he's at i i think he's
very frustrated with the state of the
world i think he's he's just
frustrated with where he is and i think
he feels very very trapped and
he just
that all comes to the forefront
you know i i think i i think it all
started with him rebelling against his
family and it really just
it really just went from there i don't
think he likes what they stand for i
don't think he likes what they are i
don't think he even really likes them
all that much except for his brother
um
and
you know there's always kind of a
counterculture
you know i grew up
me and my parents are close they're
nothing like that but
i grew up
in a very sort of
simple
kind of life and then
i actively seeked out other things like
i grew up on punk and hardcore music i
grew up going to
hardcore shows i grew up you know
running from cops with my skateboard
like it was almost like okay this is
this thing i'm gonna go the the opposite
way and steal beers from my neighbor's
garage and be drunk with my friends at
14 years old and you know running around
the golf course throwing flags into the
ponds and getting in trouble and doing
whatever
um you know i think simon just took that
in a very in a further direction
do you do you have a a background in
music or was there any uh you know
additional uh training or rehearsing
required to be able to play everything
you do here
i have a background music in the way of
like i've always wanted to have a
background in music
i never
i never really did i never played i
never
you know i never anything i've always
enjoyed like
singing in my car or whatever
um
and i love that kind of music um
you know i've had teenage fantasies of
being in a punk band or being in like a
pop punk band or i've always wished i
could just
scream like
those dudes in hardcore but i don't know
how they do it it blows my mind but i've
always wanted to just be front centered
thrown down on stage so
you know for me it was less that i
actually did it more of like i've always
fantasized about it
you know and went to shows and and
saw these guys do these things and and
so it's a world i'm familiar with it
wasn't like stepping into another planet
it was something that i'm like oh hell
yeah i could
these are shoes that i
could slip into you sell it like
incredibly well i totally believed you
had that background and i feel like now
you and emily should just like run off
and and consistently make music together
because i would listen to it yeah i mean
all those vocals in the movie that's
that is all me that's all
i recorded those i did all those um so
everything you hear
is if i if it's me singing it's me if
it's emily it's emily there's a really
great band called disco assault that had
the music
um they laid down some scratch
you know vocals and
i got to
take it in here what it was and we went
into the studio and recorded it that was
like
the day after we landed in detroit they
were like all right let's go
legit talented it's it's fantastic stuff
i'm sure you've heard this a million
times but like i don't i can't get that
song out of my head i've had it stuck in
my head for two years now and i'm happy
with it there
the watermelon song yeah the watermelon
song is incredible it's incredibly
catchy
it's unbelievable that was emily and
adam
um they sat down
we all sat down i just kind of watched
because it was like i
i was being included but also
this was their thing and i i was like i
just want to see where the hell emily's
head's at
and she had this whole like notebook of
like stream of conscious patty poetry
that she'd written
and a lot of it was just pulled from
this little notebook and her and adam
sat down
and
just
wrote this song together and it was a
really
pretty profound moment especially for me
coming from simon's point of view to
hear these insane things coming out of
this person's mouth and i'm like
this is
this is it
this is where she's coming from
like holy crap and it was really an
eye-opening moment to be like that's
patty
there she is
it was cool
absolutely can you tell me a little more
about working with emily uh maybe
is there anything she did for you as a
scene partner that you really
appreciated and maybe even helped you
find something in simon that you might
not have been able to reach without her
yeah a hundred percent i mean every day
like every day
um emily is
fearless and
worked so hard to create patty and
truthfully
i think in the wrong hands patty could
have been an absolute disaster
um
i i think it's such a difficult role and
i think and i think what she did with it
was
incredible i mean she found exactly who
she was supposed to be she didn't push
it
too far one way or the she was just so
the embodiment of this
incredible person you know and
she was like i said she was so fearless
that she
[Music]
she just pushed me every day and we
trusted each other
like we were each other's safety nets i
knew if i was gonna try something and if
i was gonna try to push it as far as i
could go emily would be there to catch
me and to be there and to either go with
it or
whatever
um so i felt very safe
with emily which for a movie like this
is incredibly important because
these characters are so big
they're so kind of over the top and in a
lot of ways but also very grounded that
you have to be at 11 the whole time or
else the film doesn't work
if you're scared and you're holding back
or your scene partners holding back and
you guys aren't taking it to where it
needs to go then this
this film
doesn't work
you know so i owe a lot to emily
actually i owe a lot to her she's
amazing
you two
both i i don't think this movie works
unless you kind of get that that pitch
perfect marriage of
of making the audience uncomfortable but
also exuding heart through your
performances and and both of you just
absolutely nail it on your own and with
your chemistry together
it does kind of make me wonder though
was there any particular thing that
simon does in the movie that proved to
be the most challenging in nailing that
balance where maybe you had a workshop
how far to push it the challenge was
just having the balls to push it
and to also not
question pushing it and to
take it there and then realize oh it's
not far enough yet you know it's almost
that mental game of like how could it go
any further and it's like well it has to
you have to go
you know
um so that that was the challenge of
like
knowing when far was not far enough
and knowing that you need to even push
it further
and being comfortable with that you know
because a lot of the stuff i've done
not a lot of it but like you know a lot
of film stuff for the most part is
pretty subtle or pretty
you know there's there's a different
thing depending on depending on
depending on the the project
you know and i haven't gotten to play a
lot of
big loud
guys like simon so like a lot of the
things i've done have been a little more
a little lower i guess you could i don't
know i don't know what the terminology
that would be but
um so it took me out of my comfort zone
for sure even though simon is probably
closer to me than
a lot of these other people that i've
played it still took me a little while
to
figure out how to really
take him to his max and to stay there
because the thing with simon is
he's pretty much there the whole movie
like he's at 11 almost the entire the
entire film all right thank you so much
for your time today kyle and for
everybody out there please trust me when
i tell you you need to see dinner in
america and you have two options for
this you could see it in theaters
beginning may 27th and it's also going
to be available on vod on june 7 so you
have no excuse go watch that movie